oh well shoots so um Christmas is
canceled or at least it is if you were
waiting for the Doctor Who Christmas
special to mark the occasion cuz uh
that's not happening
that was very sudden and unexpected news
and one that I have kind of multiple
conflicted feelings about and as is
often that happens we'll see where I
shake out at the end by the time I'm
done talking
so yeah the officially doctor who will
not have a Christmas special this year
which it has had for every year since
the show came back so this will be a
first time and thirteen goes it's yeah I
mean it's we've had a lot of these
things so it's but that doesn't mean
that there is no special between series
on the show there is still gonna be
special
it's just gonna be a New Year's special
so the reason being given is that the
writing staff headed by Chris Chibnall
is of the opinion that there really
isn't much more left for them to do with
Christmas as there's a central theme for
an episode and moving it to a holiday
that doesn't have as many that is just a
general holiday about you know new
beginnings and whatnot it doesn't tie
them down to as many things and gives
them some more freedom to sort of branch
out a little bit and honestly there's
some validity to that because let's be
completely honest how many more elements
of Christmas are there even left to
explore I mean for crying out loud we've
had we've had killer Christmas stars and
killer Christmas trees and we've had you
know Santa Claus and
we've had the Christmas Carol I mean the
I feel like in many ways the Christmas
armistice was about the last clever
thing that they really have up their
sleeve and even if you could come up
with a couple more things keep in mind
that at least as of right now Chris
Chibnall is in for a bit of a long haul
he approached BBC with a five-year plan
which means that it wouldn't have been
enough for him to say you know well you
know I can't even come up with a
Christmas idea for this year maybe he
could have but he that would be making a
commitment to keep coming up with more
Christmas stuff for down the line and
honestly I I think he's kind of got a
point
that there isn't really a ton more
mileage and a ton more you land to
conquer on that on that front so I get
that and if you're going to do a major
thing like ship the Christmas special
from Chris you know ship the special
from Christmas to New Year's enough
other things are changing at this point
this is about as clean a break because
you're going to get and it's gonna feel
less jarring the Christmas special
becomes something of the you know
Eccleston well know Eccleston didn't do
it
the the Tennant Smith compelled the era
and now starting with Whitaker's running
for who knows however long now it's a
New Year special fine and the other
thing I mean I'm also saying this coming
from the perspective of someone who
isn't in love with the Christmas
specials I think oftentimes they they
veer cheesy they you know they veered
towards kind of the pantomime tradition
at times which yeah it's fine if that's
your bag it's not mine
and it's it tends to invite you know
episodes that are lighter and kind of
fluffier by nature and you know every
now and then you get something with a
bit more heft to it but by and large the
you know it has a specific Uppal of
Christmas things Christmas seems to have
largely dictated the tone of those
episodes as well and especially if it's
a tone that Chibnall doesn't want to
play in that would make it all the more
valid he
and say that that's me speculating a
little bit but here's where at least for
my part I get annoyed by this so I came
to the conclusion earlier this year that
even though I think I'd like twice upon
a time better than a fair duck decent
chunk of people out there that I would
rather compel these last episode was the
doctor Falls I think that was a much
stronger final story for him I think
having him go out in the episode where
he gives the just be kind speech to the
master would have been much more
appropriate then you know dragging him
along for one more story and again I
actually do like twice upon a time but
dr. Falls would have been a stronger
finish and the only reason twice upon
time was made because it wasn't going to
be originally the you know Moffat wasn't
planning to do a Christmas special but
when he found out Chibnall was not
planning to do one that year and he was
just working on the next on series 11
instead then at that point Moffat
inserted it in because he was afraid
that the that the show would lose that
slot and no longer have Christmas and so
we get this additional episode that
again while I don't severely just like
the show didn't need and the reason it's
there is now moot because it's being
moved off the Christmas schedule anyway
so on that level it does irritate me I
mean you know the dominoes fall in the
order that they fall I'm pretty sure
that Chibnall had not made the final
decision that you know what I don't
think I'm gonna be doing Christmas at
all at the point of which Moffat made
the decision to insert twice upon time
in order to keep that slot you know it's
very possible that Chibnall you know
thought I mean I'll do Christmas I just
don't have one you know ready for before
starting my series and ultimately later
on decided you know what I actually
don't yeah I've been thinking about it
for a while now and I don't really have
much in the tank for this topic and
again that's fine that's legit still
irritating to me
but again I suspect there's gonna be a
lot of how can there not be a doctor Oh
Christmas special laughs it'll be one
more change for the crowd that has
already decided that they were gonna
hate this no matter what and that's not
me saying that that this has been a
perfect series so far it hasn't I've
certainly had my issues but you can tell
oftentimes in the tone of comments in
certain discourse that there are there
is I don't I've had no sense of how big
they are but there's certainly a very
vocal contingent of fans who already
decided that they were gonna hate this
before I started and then they jump on
every single thing that is different and
declare it awful and this sold this will
just add fuel to that fire which that'll
annoy me on principle but beyond that
you know I liked the Christmas specials
but I again you know I didn't grow up on
them I was an adult when the show came
back on the air so maybe maybe it's more
of a loss for people who you know we're
watching it we're marching that
regularly as a family tradition as a kid
or even you know as an adult if it
became a family tradition
I get you know being sad about losing
that but like what else was there left
to do with Christmas I I do kind of
agree with Chibnall on that and and some
of the even in the times family we've
had some of them are really thinly
connected to Christmas and but it always
feels very conciliatory but again it
largely felt like it dictated the tone
more than anything else and the tone
that was usually in those episodes not
my thing so ya know Doctor Who Christmas
special we will get a special just not
Christmas so what are your thoughts
about that
whatever they are draw something out in
the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff you can do down there too
because there's links and there's
buttons and stuff they do things and
take you places include you get my
patreon page if you feel like supporting
the channel in that fashion
if you don't though don't sweat it
there's other stuff
check out you don't have to look at any
of it if you don't want cuz at the end
of the day you guys are the council I
might just run the meetings so until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]